the country may have been better off by  donald trump not getting those briefings  after that period of time  if he was getting the briefings at that  point when he was completely triggered  unhinged off the rails trying to steal  back the election  who knows what he might have done with  the information from the briefings who  knows where he might have blabbed about  information from the briefings and this  is so insane  but in a weird way it's almost slightly  reassuring that trump wasn't being  briefed at the time now it's important  to remember as the article sort of  mentions he wasn't really getting much  in the way of briefings to begin with  for the majority of his presidency he  wasn't reading them former president you  know obama bush  they would get a multi-page briefing  mostly text and they would read it and  then they might have follow-up questions  for an in-person briefing trump wasn't  reading it